yeah so my name is Kasia and I work in
the sales forecasting team here at
solando and those of you don't know the
londo it's one of the leading European
fashion platforms with a yearly revenue
of 3 billion euros and around 18 million
active customers and at solando tech
here in Berlin we have about a thousand
500 developers and scientists and if
you're interested there's a booth here
as well especially because as Marty said
solando is hiring developers and data
scientists ok so the motivation for this
talk came from this tweet and I cannot
possibly talk about all of these topics
here but what I wanted to do was talk
about some of the major new things which
are a bit more practical for your deep
learning kind of if you're doing any
deep learning then it should be helpful
to you to know these new newer things
like batch normalization and residual
networks so you can kind of start using
them but even if you're new to deep
learning I hope you'll get some
intuition about how some of these things
work so so that not everyone is lost
I've first wanted to just quickly
introduce deep learning in the minimal
of slides and if you've done any deep
learning I hope there's some information
here as well for you next I wanted to
dive into the issues of deep learning
and how they are solved these days and
in order to try to train deep networks
and finally we'll try and implement what
we've learned using chaos one of the
Python deep learning frameworks ok and
we'll have questions and answers later
but you can ask anyways so the
supervised data-driven approach of
neural networks is kind of loosely based
on how children learn labels by looking
at many examples of the world around
them and similarly in this approach
we do is we give our model many examples
many examples of here these examples are
represented by this vector X I together
with some labels for these examples and
in the simplest case I have my my model
which is just a linear model which is
just multiplying my vector by some
matrix W which we can choose alright so
at a very high level deep learning can
be broken down into three aspects this
score function or the predict function
the model itself based on some parameter
W or the weight matrix W and depending
on how happy we are with the performance
of this on our actual data we can define
a loss function as well Li for each of
the of our training examples alright and
then we have a total loss which is just
average over all the losses and together
with the regularization term but don't
worry about it if you don't know what
that is and finally what we need to do
is we need to optimize this loss with
respect to the weights why our gradient
descent and you know in other words what
we do is we change the weights in the
direction of their steepest descent till
we find a local minimum then given some
this optimal weight that we found we can
predict new labels for any new data by
just using our score function alright so
that's the core idea here and so that
was a simple linear case neural networks
are essentially the same approach but
now you have compositions of many
functions to you compose many functions
together which encode kind of
corresponds to matrix vector
multiplication and the gradient of the
loss with respect to the to the weights
you calculate Y the chain rule and with
that you can then update your initial
weight so that the loss can be minimized
all right so that's essentially what's
going on here in code you can do
essentially the same thing here your you
can see my first for I have to I have to
parameters wh and wo and the first the
first time I'm out I'm multiplying them
together with my ex and then running it
through a non-linearity this hinge
function the max of 0 and and matrix
vector multiplication and then I take
that and then I dot dot it with the
second multiply with the second wait so
that's the composition and then run it
through some other say some other
non-linearity here and then that's my
output all right so what we then do is
we can initialize our weights to
something which I will talk about later
why this init in why this in it weights
function and then our predicted label is
just the index of the maximum
probability returned by the model so
that's the the Y hat here everyone see
this yeah as I mentioned optimization
involves calculating the gradient of the
cost with respect to our parameters and
then updating the parameters in the
direction of the steepest descent here
the cost is the categorical cross entry
which is a measure of how two
probabilities probability distribution
differ from each other and we want our
models probability to be the same as
that of our training data and so this
this cost here makes sense notice now in
our my stochastic gradient descent we
don't really need to calculate the
gradient of the cost with respect to the
parameters explicitly since the N or the
framework I'm using here does that
automatically which is really really a
great awesome thing all right kind of
like magic and once I have the gradients
I update my parameters in the direction
of the of the steepest descent that's
what's going on here with a small step
size or learning rate which is 0.01 in
this case a large step size will have me
bouncing around the cost landscape and a
tiny one will have me making very will
have me proceeding at a snail's pace
more or less so it's a it's a hyper
parameter so then training involves
taking
batches of our training data and then
labels and calling trained on them which
then calls updates that optimize the
parameters to minimize the cross entropy
loss or the difference between the
predicted labels and probabilities
predicted label probabilities and actual
labels and we iterate this 20 times
across our training data after which we
hopefully end up with some parameters
which we can use to make future
predictions on unseen data all right so
that's the core essence of deep learning
in some sense as I said deep learning is
a lot like then these playing with Lego
because you can choose between a wide
variety of different layers stack them
up why this functional composition
approach but if you did not have this
automatic differentiation which we
should have in piano then our layer API
would look something like this each
layer would have a four word method
which is essentially doing a matrix
vector multiplication and then some
non-linearity applied to it and then a
backward method where we calculate the
gradients and propagate them back down
the layers all right
via some stored operations when we do
the forward call or so one could then
think you could be able to make deeper
and deeper networks to solve all kinds
of problems but it turns out there's a
catch here as well
deeper networks are notoriously hard to
Train so let's talk about that quickly
so one issue here is the those initial
parameters we need to think about how we
initialize them since if we start off
with very small weights the signal might
shrink to zero or we as we go forward
meaning that no gradient changes come
back why about back propagation which
means that our training essentially
either slows down or just halts which is
not good on the other hand if the
weights are too big they might overflow
as well and so you you
that's also not good so what we want is
for our weights to be in some reasonable
range and this paper from 2010 from claw
wrote and been Geo presents such an
initialization scheme and if you get the
slides all these are links or everything
that's on underlined are links to the
papers so let's discuss this game since
it's not too complicated to get into and
get an intuition of what just-right
means so suppose we have a single layer
with any incoming inputs and a neuron
with the random weights W that return
just a single value F as F as W times X
without any non-linearity applied to it
just like in the linear case before so
the question is what is the variance of
this F well you can calculate the
variance of each individual entry in
this sum and if you assume both the
inputs and the weights have same mean
zero then this term and this term term
are essentially zero and so you end up
with the variance of F being just ni
times the variance of our X's and the
variance of the weights WI
so one desirable property that we want
is for the variance of the incoming data
incoming signal to be the same as the
output so that the variance kind of
stays the same and one way to achieve
that if you look in this equation is if
we set our variance of WI to be 1 on the
number of incoming neurons here so so
that's one thing we could do similarly
if we go through the same calculation in
the backpropagation signal we end up
with a similar equation where we want
the variance of wi to be 1 over the
number of outgoing signals neurons and
that's to keep the input and output
signal to be the same we want we will
need to have the number of income
neurons and the number of outgoing
neurons to be the same which is not
really realistic in a network
architecture and so the author's
proposes compromise where you have to
divide by and in plus and out and in
most libraries implement this as the
normal variant of the glory glory
initialization or the Xavier
initialization depends on which name the
first or last name of the main author
they use
note again the very big assumption here
the very big assumption is that the
network consists only of matrix vector
multiplication without any
nonlinearities applied to it a real
networks obviously violate this
assumption because you always have some
onion reading long linearity but in many
strategies designed for the linear
method perform reasonably well on their
nonlinear counterpart and so this this
scheme for initializing our weight is
not really such a bad idea anyways going
to 2015 now this recent paper from
Microsoft Research extends the results
of gloried by considering real ooh or
this hinge function Nonya non-linearity
in which case the variance of the output
is not the product of the variance of
the weights anymore because the mean of
the riilu is not zero anymore
so this leads to a different
initialization namely the weights need
to be sampled from a zero mean Gaussian
distribution whose standard deviation is
given by square root of two divided by
the number of incoming neurons all right
and in code this initialization is
either either call the he normal or
sometimes it's called severe two because
because of the two here all right so we
can we have now this we can initialize
our weights now
but unfortunately these optimal criteria
for initial weights often do not lead to
optimal performance and there's a number
of reasons for this firstly we may be
using the wrong criteria it may not
actually be beneficial to preserve the
norms of a signal throughout the entire
network another reason could be that the
property is imposed by initialization
may not persist after the learning has
begun thirdly the criteria might succeed
at improving the speed of optimization
but in it might end up increasing the
generalization error so you might be
overfitting also scaling rules that set
the initial weights to the same standard
deviation means that every individual
weight becomes very tiny when you have
layers with a lot of a lot of say
incoming or outgoing neurons and one way
around that is to have to initialize
your weight of each unit to have it say
exactly K non zero weight which is
called sparse initialization but that
also has its own issues so in terms of
optimizing deep learning dispatch
normalization introduced in this 2015
paper from Google is one of the most
exciting development and I would like to
talk about that now it's not really an
optimization algorithm but rather a
method to adaptively
reprise motivated by the issues of what
we talked about so very deep neural
network involved the composition of
several functions or layers which means
we have many interactions of features
when we update a parameter it's under
the assumption that all other layers
don't change but in practice we update
these layers all at once and so you
could you typically end up with these
interaction terms doing unexpected
things and this patch anonymization
significantly reduces
the issues of coordinating updates
across many layers by reprimanding the
data and this can be applied to any
input or hidden layers in the network so
essentially it's it's a layer of its own
so during the forward pass of training
the sample mean and uncorrelated sample
variance are computed from the
mini-batches to statistics and used to
normalize the incoming data to have mean
0 and variance 1 and we also keep
exponentially decaying running average
of the mean and variance of each feature
and these averages are used to normalize
data for during test time when we do the
prediction and the great thing now is
that during the backward pass we can
write out the gradient of the forward of
the batch normalization layer and
propagate it back down the layers which
means that the gradient will never
propose an operation that acts simply to
increase the standard deviation or mean
of the activation and in fact the
normalization removes the effects of
such operations and zeros out the
components of the gradient and this is
nice because this is the really great
thing about batch normalization since
previous approaches used some kind of
penalties to the cost function to
encourage the activations to have mean 0
and variance 1 but this resulted in
imperfect normalization and really time
wasted during training so batch
normalization is really helpful in that
but if you just add batch normalization
to your network you'll not necessarily
end up increasing the speed of your
training in order to do so you also need
to make some further changes to begin
with what you need to do is you should
also increase your learning rate batch
normalization also regular Liza's
similarly to drop out if you know drop
out it's a technique for randomly that
which randomly drops units and their
connections during training to prevent
prevent the network from Co adapting too
much so removing dropout will also speed
up training without increasing any
overfitting
because of this faster learning it's
best to also anneal the the the learning
rate faster as you train compared to
without batch normalization and over
each epoch it might be also beneficial
to shuffle the training data so that the
sample example so that the same examples
do not always appear in the mini batches
and this randomized nature of Bashan
normalization means that the method will
be better when it's applied to examples
differently each time so shuffling more
thoroughly is really helps a lot
finally again because of the faster
training the network might observe
training examples fewer times so it's
best that the network focuses more on
real data rather than distorted or
augmented ones which are sometimes added
for to increase to make the network more
general ok all right so we have those
two techniques now so and now let me
switch to this diagram here those of you
who don't know this image niche
classification it's a challenge involves
classifying images from a thousand
categories and so with strategies like
normalization and batch with like
initialization and Bachelor
normalization in mind if we look at the
performance of image net challenge
winners over the last five year five
years we see that we started with the
kind of very shallow models in the first
two years of the image net which is
achieved around 25% error and then in
2012 the first deep networks came to
image net which reduced the error by a
whopping 10% all right and these first
networks were around eight layers and in
the last two years we've have some two
very deep neural networks in the form of
Google net and vgg net wood which have
around 20 layers alright and last
December the winner was this was this
crazy network with a
152 layers and it achieved top-5 error
of 3.5 7% and this trend of increasing
Network layers is kind of in is also you
observe it also in other image or object
detection challenges as well or in other
computer vision challenges as well
typically for image detection task one
uses convolutional layers and if you
don't know a convolution layer is just a
layer which always does the same thing
it transforms an input 3d volume in this
case of 32 by 32 by 3 image RGB image
into another 3d volume by convolving
a number of small filter spatially over
the input volume so in other words we
take a small filter so in the first case
we take say a 5 by 5 by 3 filter and
dotted with this dotted with this image
and and then we move it especially
across this filter spatially across this
image till until we end up with till we
end up with another another image and if
we do that with say six other six other
six different filters we can stack those
filters together to end up with the
volume again alright
and typically we also have a
non-linearity applied after the
convolution like the reloj in this case
and the gradient of the convolution is
also convolution and turns out that GPUs
are very good at doing these sorts of
operations quickly and one can say that
faster GPUs are one of the reasons why
deep learning has become popular I
however am of the opinion that's because
of the it's because of the real ooh I
love the real ooh alright so here's the
visualization of the winning
architectures which as I mentioned were
built using different layers like Lego
blocks and it's not important what the
layers are but 2014 Google net looks
kind of complicated
but if you can spot it is essentially
made up of nine of the same blocks here
so there are just nine of the same
blocks and each in each of these blocks
there's other there's another network
all right so this architecture is called
the inception because of this fact of
network inside a network so it might
look complicated but it's not too
complicated so this is 2014 and here's
the 2015 architecture called the
residual net or resonant again don't
worry about the details but just by just
by glancing at it it doesn't look too
special it just has a lot of layers
copied and pasted hundreds of times
and we'll go into go into that in a
second but the main question we want to
ask now is that is learning better
networks just as easy as stacking more
layers of course one issue with
exploring this question is the things we
talked about at the start but
normalization normalized innocent
initializations and the addition of
master normalization layers allows us to
run back propagation on say the Google
net or vgg net size networks till they
converge but what about say 50 or 100
layer network well if we try it strange
thing happens the networks start to
converge but then the the the networks
themselves get saturated and then the
the the the accuracy of the network
starts to degrade and you might think
that this problem is called by caused by
overfitting but that's not the case by
adding more layers to the deeper models
leads to a higher tester as shown on the
right but it also leads to a higher
training error shown on the Left graph
so it's not overfitting or feeling is
not
and this experiment was done with the
CFR ten data and consider consists of
adding stacking 3x3 convolutional layers
but this phenomena also occurs with
other datasets so it's this problem is
not the data set either so it's not
overfitting and it's not the data set so
it's kind of counterintuitive and here
is a construction which shows that a
deep model should not have higher
training error so if we have a shallow
model say of 18 layers and if we copied
this original layers from the shallow
model into a deeper one where we set for
the the new layers we set their weights
to be identity to be the identity weight
then both of these networks should have
the same training error so the
construction then indicates this
construction indicates that the
phenomena that we see when we stack more
and more layers is is due to the
optimization where the gradient descent
solver cannot find the solution when we
go to deeper networks so to motivate
deep residual networks we first look at
for example two layers in a plane
Network usually we expect these two
layers to fit some underlying some
underlying true mapping denoted here by
H of X and when you have many such
layers you expect some of these to fit
their own optimal underlying mapping
after training all right
so that's the case and the the job of
the gradient the solver is to find this
underlying find the weights to get to
these under the optimal under lying
mapping as quickly as possible so
instead of hoping that any say two
layers fit the desired mapping H of X
the resonant paper from 2015 hopes that
the two layers fit some mapping denoted
here by by f of X and at the same time
they use the
short cut connection which is just
identity mapping which directly passes
all the information past the two layers
and is added back to the output of the
two layers so in this way the function
represented by the two layers given by f
of X this f of X plays the role of
fitting to the residual mapping of the
desired optimum map H of X so if H of X
was our optimal mapping what f of X is
doing is it is fitting to the the
residual so if the the idea is that if
the identity were the optimal mapping
then the the then setting F to zero
would be is a is very easy for the
gradient descent on the other hand if
the optimal mapping was close to the
identity then the authors also state
that's also easy for the solver to find
say small perturbations of the weights
and that's by chaining a lot of these
these units we can we can essentially
get very deep networks we can get these
very deep networks to Train all right
and these shortcut connections have been
used in numerical PDS and and sorry the
residual connection residual solving the
residual problem have been used in in a
number of numerical fields and this
shortcut connections have also been
studied for a long time in multi-layer
perceptrons starting with adding a
linear layer connected from the network
input - its output in the book from
Ripley and recent papers also use a few
intermediate layers which are directly
connected to auxilary classifiers for
addressing say the vanishing gradient or
the or the exploding gradient problem
and the inception layer I we talk oops
the inception layer we talked about the
Google net also does something similar
also the recent highway networks from
the 2015 paper by Schmidt who by the
schmidhuber group introduces shortcut
connections with gating functions these
gates are data dependent and have
parameters in contrast to the to the
parameter free identity shortcut in
resonance when a gated shortcut is
closed or near zero the layer is in
highway networks represent non residual
functions residual networks on the other
hand always learn residual function
since the identity shortcut is never
closed right so in the indicated Network
you have a you can close close that gate
all right the original resident paper
actually had no network design had just
a single equation and instead there's a
new paper by the original authors that
came out in 2016 which improves the
residual net principle the residual net
improves on the residual net principle
and the first principle being to keep
things as simple as possible next what
they do is they propose the batch
normalization and the real real uu
layers to come before the weight layers
this has two benefits first the
optimization is further eased compared
to the baseline resonant because we now
have a true identity mapping second the
batch normalization in this
configuration improves it regularization
of the models as well so all the
convolution layers are always three by
three layers and each time the they in
in this architecture they reduce the
spatial size of the input by say two
they increase the number of filters by
they they multiply the number of filters
by two so they keep the complexity of
the of these layer of these convolution
layers to be the same again they use the
Savior to the he the he normal
initialization and they also have
increased learning rate as well so again
the design is very simple the main
purpose being going deeper and this 2016
papers architecture the authors are able
to train a network of a thousand layers
so an order of magnitude more than the
2015 entry so here's the results for the
C 410 data on the Left our results of
the plane
network which you can which which has
the problem using you saw before as we
increase the layers the both the tests
and training error increased on the
right are the residual networks which
can be trained without difficulty
starting from say 20 210 layers in this
experiment and this has lower training
error and lower test error as well
alright so this might be a good time to
show you how easy it is to implement
such a residual network with Charis
Charis has a new functional api and if
we just look at the network in the
network more or less consists of a
number of residual units where the
number of the filters the size of the
filters doesn't change so we have 64 64
64 so you have a number of them and then
sun and then another number where the
and the size of the filter changes so if
we were to implement it we need kind of
a helper function that that gives gets
us from one layer to the one one batch
of these these units to the next one so
that's what this this function is doing
the first time it it creates a unit from
some incoming number filters to an
outgoing one and for the rest of these
counts the input and output filters are
the same okay so it's just a helper
function to so I can I can chain things
like this alright so what's the bottom
bottle neck unit the model neck unit is
just two we have whoops
we have two cases the first is when
there's no change in the in the incoming
and outgoing number of filters and there
I take my I take my input I apply again
the Bahamas ation I apply now the
activation so here's the Kira's
functional API in action so it is the
input now the Y gets changed then we
have the convolution and we keep keep
doing that and then in the end we
we have our shortcut connection here so
the original ex gets merged with the Y
which is here why this plus and then we
return we return this so essentially
this is what it is in the other case we
need to do essentially the same but keep
in but we need to increase as I said the
number of filters if when the when the
spatial size decreases by half so I
won't show you that so here's the
complete network we have our input
images which have some channels number
of channels some size in this loops in
this case is 32 by 32 we start with one
conversion layer and then for say N
equals three so it's not such a big
network because I'm running it locally
we have our first first batch of
resonance and then the second one and
then the third one all right and they're
chained and then at the end we have
another batch normalization and then a
real ooh and then an average pooling and
then a softmax so I get my predictions
and then the model is just the input
images and just this output predictions
I'm using atom optimizer and loss again
is the categorical cross entropy and the
metric is just accuracy and then all I
need to do is call fit with my data with
a certain batch size and some validation
test data and make sure that shuffle is
set to true or then and that starts to
train and it converges and you can kind
of experiment with with that okay so I
think I'll just stop and summarize so I
hope you learned a little bit about the
assumptions of these weight
initializations you learned a little bit
about the issues of with training and
learning please use bash normalization
but
if you use passion organization there's
certain things you have to change even
after passion organization you learned
that it's so difficult to train deep
networks and then I should now know
residual networks because it's easier to
Train the residual than the actual
function and the code is also there's a
gist of this code which you can get from
this between link alright so I'll stop
here for questions okay we're a little
short of time in time okay yeah we'll
take one question make it good the
answer might be to look at the paper
okay I hope it's a good question thanks
for the great talk when you show when
you showed the graph with the test and
training error or for networks of
triphala their size yes so it always
looks like that it's like exponentially
decreasing and and then there's the
certain cliff so there's a plateau yeah
maybe then some annealing comes in and
so then it trains a bit better yeah okay
so this was what's the intuition behind
that cliff but thanks okay that was our
question so thank you again to catch
chief and feel free to stay for the next
stop